[Music]
tell us about a lower bound on the
positive so thanks a lot Cynthia and
thanks a lot for the organizers for
inviting me so I'll talk about a lower
bond and a PhD rank of convex bodies but
really this work is actually a
connection between the PSD rank and
something called the algebraic degree of
semi definite programming which is a
quantity introduced by so Germany a
crystal - Todd and Bernie Schoenfeld
which I will explain in in the talk okay
so so so just to make sure we're all on
the same page so I want to if the
definition so I'm working essentially
the main concept of this talk is the
notion of a semi definite lift okay so
if I have sees a convex body I say see
how the semi definite lift if it can be
written in the following form it's a
projections or the image under a linear
map of a spectral hebron okay so a
spectral hildren is a set defined using
a linear matrix inequality so so you
have matrices symmetric matrices of size
M say a 0 up to a n and you look at the
set of X such that this linear matrix is
positive semi definite that's a spectra
hydron and if you can project this and
you get see this is this is a semi
definite lift and the size of the lift
is going to be the size of the matrices
m and the PhD rank of a convex body is
the size of the smallest SDP left of
this convex body okay
so this is an example of SDP lift so
this is a linear matrix inequality here
this describes a certain convex setting
in three dimensions X 1 X 2 and you this
is the set that you see here and if you
project it on X 1 and X 2 you get the
square so this is an SDP lift of size 3
of the square of minus 1
yes so so so how do we actually
construct SDP lifts oh so there's a we
have a general method of constructing a
stipulation based on the sum of squares
method
so essentially you try to certify all
the valid linear inequalities of your
convex sets using sums of squares from a
certain low dimensional subspace and
this gives you a certain SDP lift so
there's a nice theory behind this so but
what I'd be interested in here in a
season isn't trying to prove optimality
of certain lifts so essentially in
trying to prove lower bounds on on the
PSD rank because actually the PSD rank
of some very basic convex sets is still
unknown okay so if you look at the
regular polygons and the planes with
these shapes this convex bodies here we
don't know what they're PSD rank is or
for example the PhD mark of the
parameter he'd run this this object here
which is the the convex hull of all
possible permutations of the vector 1 2
3 up to n this convex set we also don't
know what what it's PSD rank is and in
fact the main motivation for this work
is actually a very simple fact about LP
lifts and which is an observation due to
Michele Bachmann's so so first what is
an LP lift of a polytope so an LP lift
of a polytope is a representation of a
polytope as the projection of another
polyhedron ok and the size of the of
this representation is the number of
facets of the polyhedron upstairs so so
we heard about this in the first couple
of talks and so I'm going to call the
the LP rank or the non-negative rank of
a polytope is the smallest size of an LP
lift okay so the observation of
Grauman's tells us that the if P is a
polytope then the non-negative rank of P
or the smallest LP formulation of P is
at least the logarithm of the number of
vertices of the polytope
okay and the proof is very simple so
what is the proof so assume that I can
write P as the projection of a certain
polyhedron Q which has M facets I want
to lower bound M so the main observation
is that if I take a vertex of my poly
tope P and I look at its pre image in Q
this is going to be a face of Q okay
this is not difficult to show and and
and then we use kind of a crucial
property of polyhedra is that any face
of
is an intersection of facets and because
I have M facets okay I can have at most
2 2 DM such faces okay so essentially
the number of so what we've shown is
that the number of vertices is at most 2
to the M where m is the number of facets
of my of queue and so I have I have this
normal ok so it's a very simple result
ok and my so the motivation for this
work was to try to find a similar kind
of lower bound for for for this because
in fact this this bound turns actually
to be turns out to be tight for these
examples that I mentioned before so for
the regular n-gon the LP extension
complex of the regular n-gon is Logan
and for the parameter hidden also this
bound turns out to be tight so how can
we kind of generalize this to get a
lower bound on the PSD rank so there is
one first kind of idea that that one can
try and that and that one can can
implement which is the idea based on on
quantifier elimination so so the idea is
as follows so so first actually we have
to observe that since if we're working
with SDP lifts and and if I work with a
convex body so I need to find kind of
another notion other than the number of
vertices and it's not very difficult to
see that the kind of the relevant notion
that you would want to work with is the
degree of the boundary of the convex set
ok so if you look at the convex set you
can look at its boundary okay that's a
hyper surface okay so you can look at
what the smallest degree of a polynomial
that vanishes on this hyper surface okay
and this is the quantity that will that
will show up instead of this so so so so
let's let's try to implement this this
this line of thought so assume that I
have a convex body see and and it's a
projection of a certain spectra he'd run
okay I know this spectra hidden is a
similar break set so I can write
polynomials that define this this
spectra he'd run for example by looking
at all the minors and saying that
they're non negative or by using
something a bit better than say that the
cut rule of sign on and on the
determinant of the characteristic
polynomial of this and then by using
results based on quantify elimination
these results allow us to to to get a
description of the projection of s ok so
so of see
and and the complexity analysis of this
quantified elimination algorithms would
actually tell us how many polynomials
you will need to describe C and what is
the degree of these polynomials and so
essentially it will it will tell us it
will give us an upper bound on the
degree of the boundary of this convex
set C so so in fact if you if we
implement this result and use the the
the kind of the whammer's if you ordered
a really heavy wet results from
quantified elimination then we get that
the PhD rank of the convex of the any
convex body C is bigger than this than
this quantity so here this is a root of
log D over n log log D where D here is
the degree of the bounden of my convex
body so that's the smallest degree of a
polynomial that vanishes on the boundary
of of C and an N is the dimension of my
convex body so is this is this kind of
so so so one I mean so I think one major
drawback about I mean about this this
lower bound is that the the constants
here are really not explicit I mean if
we look at these complexity results in
quantify elimination there they involved
a lot of constants that are actually
very large I mean they're often not
explicit and and most likely they're
very large and and another kind of
drawback of this is that we don't have a
way really to check whether this is
tight because we're using somehow in a
black box way this results from
quantified elimination so we cannot
really know if these are actually tight
or not so so the results that I want to
present today is it's kind of a way to
to find a lower bound in the same spirit
but with with with actually explicit
constants so so this is so these are the
results so so the results uses the
result that I'm going to present using a
crucian way the notion of a polar of a
convex body C so so the polar lives in
the dual space and the space of linear
functions again it's the set of linear
functions that attains a maximum of at
most one on C and so so the first result
which is the lower bound it tells us
that if C is a convex body and these the
smallest degree of a polynomial that
vanished
on the boundary of the polar so now this
is the quantity that shows up in the
lower bound then the PhD rank is at
least root of log d so so just to be
sure I mean if C is a polytope okay if C
is a polytope then then the polar
essentially the the facets of the polar
are really the vertices of my of my poly
tope and so D here is going to be the
number of vertices of the polytope
because you need I mean if you if you
have a poly tope with with the D facets
than the degree of the smallest
polynomial that vanishes on the boundary
is d because you need exactly one linear
polynomial per facet of of the of the
pollito so so so this is the lower bound
we get you know it can vanish also I
mean it's yes and in fact so so okay
later in the talk I'll talk about the
algebra at the algebraic boundary of a
convex set so this is actually the
smallest what we call this most
algebraic variety that that that
contains the the boundary of a convex
set
ok so I'll get to this a bit later so so
this is the lower bound and in fact so
we should also that this lower bound is
studied so we show that there exists
convex bodies such that the PSD rank is
that most rule I mean some constant
times root log D ok and D can be made or
between large so this is this is so it's
the statement of the theorem clear or is
there any any questions about this so
again for polytopes this would be d here
would be really the number of vertices
so ok maybe I should mention this the
PhD rank of a convex body and of its
polar are equal so so you can also put
this to be the degree of the thing that
virus on and the boundary of C but in
fact the reason I put the polar is
because the pole
really a crucial tool that we use in the
in the proof so it would be kind of
hiding something yes
so it just has to vanish on the boundary
so yeah exactly yeah it just exactly yes
you could have the max yes yeah yeah
exactly so okay let me give an example
then because the idea this just to
clarify this so so if I have a spectra
hidden like this okay I claim there is a
polynomial of degree M okay that
vanishes on the boundary of this okay so
can you give it to me so what the
determinant exactly okay so so but in
general the polar of this thing will
have the boundary of the boundary of the
polar of this will actually have a
degree that is much larger than this but
for spectra Hedra defined using matrix
of size m it is when of course you can
make it symmetric between primal and the
world and taking the maximum if you look
at secrecy polar and and oh yeah I
didn't think of this I may be desertion
myself
any other questions about the statement
is the statement kind of clear so now I
want to okay so the in order to prove
this result I want to kind of forget a
little bit about lift and go back to
something very standard in optimization
which is a KKT system KKT constraints so
let's assume I have a certain semi
definite program like this so I want to
maximize C transpose X subject to this
linear matrix inequality okay so we know
from standard convex optimization that a
point X is optimal if it if there exists
a certain dual variable Z such that the
following KKT system is satisfied let's
Kurush kuhn tucker these are three
people so this is the primal feasibility
then we have dual feasibility which is
this and this and then we have the
complementary slackness which is this so
but essentially the key point to know
about this is that this is a polynomial
system so we have this the quadratic
equations in X and Z these are linear
equations in Zed and these are
inequalities in X and Z so so I want to
deal with polynomial equations only so I
want to get rid somehow of these
inequalities and then the question that
I'm going to ask is let's try to let's
let's just get rid of these inequalities
and let's think just of this polynomial
system and let's ask what are the
solutions of this polynomial system okay
so this is a valid question that that I
could ask okay so first I can I can
actually ask are there just a finite
number of solution I mean I know there
is only one unique solution of this
system now I can ask is there just one
unique solution to this is there
finitely number of solutions is there
actually a manifold say of dimension
what is the dimension of the solutions
and so on so so let's rewrite so of this
is exactly the same system that you saw
before but I've just rewritten it some
introduced X just to stand for a of X
and the first fact that one should know
about this system of KKT equations is
that this system is actually has a
finite number of solutions only this is
something that you can prove and the
reason so this is formally this is an
application of
what we call the Bertini theorem but
it's actually not very easy to see I
mean you don't really need to know
Bertini theorem to to believe this
statement so so the reason for this is
that if we look at the structure of this
polynomial system so this is a certain
variety defined using quadratic
equations and this these are two linear
equations so were essentially
intersecting a certain variety with a
certain subspace so if you compute the
dimension of this variety and the
dimension of this subspace you will find
if the dimension of this variety say is
K you can show the code I mention of
this subspace is K also and so we know
that if you have a manifold of dimension
K we're intersecting with a subspace of
ku dimension K you get something of
dimension 0 so you can show that this is
a zero dimension variety so this is
essentially what happens and you need
the AIS to be generic so that you don't
have and things don't mess up so so this
is why we have the generousity
assumption on uneasier optimum and this
is really not difficult to see and so
then now we can ask how many solutions
does it have ok and now now this is what
we're going to use the big blue bound ok
so what is the base root bound so the
big blue bound essentially tells you
that if you have a system of polynomial
equations and you knew that this system
has only a finite number of solutions in
the complex numbers then the number of
such solutions is upper bounded by the
product of the degrees of these
polynomials so if we look at this system
I have here M Squared polynomials of
degree 2 okay and then here these are
all linear equations and so I have 2 to
the M Squared I mean if I apply the Basu
bound to the system I get 2 to the M
square essentially this this argument I
mean these two lines tell me that this
system generically has 2 to the M
squared solutions in the complex numbers
so and and this is where the notion of
algebraic degree comes into play is that
now in these papers over j1 Christian
and burned yes what is actually the
exact number of solutions to this system
so this just gives us an upper bound so
what is the exact number of solutions
and this is what the notion of the
algebraic degree of semi definite
programming comes into play this is
actually the exact number
in fact more precisely so what they do
is that they look at the irreducible
decomposition of this variety and they
compute the the degree of each
irreducible component okay but I will
skip this part maybe I'll get I'll get
back to it a bit later in the proof of
the other of the other part but but is
this kind of are these two points okay
so so now let's go back to to our our
let's prove our lower bound so like the
proof is very simple so if I have a
convex body C and I assume that it's the
projection of a certain spectra he'd run
so what I will do is that I will exhibit
a system of polynomial equations that
vanish on the boundary of the of the
polar okay and in fact it turns out that
this system is nothing but they KKT
equations are nothing but they kick it
to equation three okay so let me let me
try to explain this so so what does it
mean for a point C to be on the boundary
of the polar okay so this means that
it's maximum on C is equal to one okay
but then I know that that I know that C
has a semi definite representation so I
can rewrite this this optimization
problem here I can rewrite it as a
certain semi definite problem okay so
this is this is a spectra hydrant so
this is the same I definitely customize
star of C where PI star is just the
adjoint of off point so so now this is
an SDP so I can I can equivalent I mean
I can write that this is this statement
here is equivalent to a certain system
of KKT conditions okay so this is
equivalent to to the existence of a
certain set such that this is true okay
and now let me get rid of these
inequalities and let me just keep these
these polynomial equations so so what
I've shown essentially is that if C lies
on the boundary of the polar of C then
these polynomial equations have to be
true so so what we have shown essential
is that we have a certain polynomial
system that vanishes on the boundary of
C and so if I just look at the degree of
this polynomial system this will give me
an upper bound on the degree of the of
the polar of the boundary of the polar
of C and so again by
using baizhu bound I mean this is
exactly the same argument that we saw in
the previous slide we get we know that
we get our result essentially that be
that that there is a polynomial of
degree at most 2 to the M Squared that
vanishes on the on the boundary of the
polar of C so I mean I've skipped
something here is that I mean I've
skipped a small detail here because we
were dealing with that with a finite
number of solutions to the KKT system
here we're losing we're working kind of
with this hyper surface but but it's
it's really I mean there is just a small
technical detail that it's this is
really just the idea essentially just
apply Bayes rule bound on the system so
this is really the lower bound are there
I mean this proves the lower bound
because then you just invert this
function on root loop T so are there any
questions about yes a plus C a symmetric
because yeah so that's actually a good
point yeah so we didn't try to optimize
very much so we just said yeah this is
so so so these two is through amz they
are symmetric so eight times that is not
necessarily symmetric so that's why I
have an M Squared I don't have an M plus
1 choose 2 here maybe it could be
optimized I don't know
it's actually asymptotically it's this
yeah yeah I will talk about this in the
in the in the other party but but before
I do so is there any question about this
proof a general idea is it is it clear
so let me now prove to I mean now I want
to show that this bound is essentially
tie it up to constants ok and this is
where I will crucially use the formulas
for the algebraic degree I read
we didn't use that much about PSD mess
or I guess yes yeah it's true we forget
about this somehow yeah but yeah but
that's okay so let me know okay this was
kind of an illustration of this so you
can actually implement linear matrix
inequality that projects on the Pentagon
and then I essentially just compute I
look at this variety defined by these
equations and I plot it using maple and
I observe that I actually do get the
boundary of the polar of the pentagon
which is a slightly rotated Pentagon but
actually what we observe is that you
also obtain some components that do not
belong to the boundary that are spurious
okay so I'll come back to this also so
so now let's let's move on because in a
bit of time so okay this was another
application in in upper bounding the
number of vertices of convex bodies so
essentially it's a vertex of a convex
body is a point where the normal cone is
full dimensional so so this was studied
by Monique for example for the ellipta
poor she showed that the vertices of the
elliptical are exactly this cut matrices
so and I think Levent also had a paper
on vertices of certain certain spectra
Hydra and their shadows and so but we
couldn't actually find in the literature
any upper bound on vertices so so this
kind of a corollary of our result is
that it it says that any that if I have
a convex body with an SDP representation
of size M then it has at most 2 to the M
Squared vertices because essentially
each vertex of C has to contribute a
linear factor in the boundary of the of
the polar
okay so how do we prove then the the the
fact that this is tight so so the convex
bodies for which this will be title
random spectra Hydra so these are chosen
generically somehow so so okay let me I
want to yeah so this is really the main
point of the result is that so so if I
take C to be a generic spectra he drawn
okay defined using a certain linear
matrix inequality like this then we know
that the so okay maybe I have five
minutes I just want to write something
where is the so so what so so remember
the so I have and I also have so so we
saw that if I look at this polynomial
system so where my where my these are my
variables really so so if I look at this
polynomial system which I project and
see we saw I mean the argument we saw
before is that this is a polynomial
system that vanishes on the boundary of
the polar okay so now I can also do so
if we if you want to understand
irreducible decomposition of this system
you essentially what you want to do is
to put rank constraints on on X okay so
you put rank effects smaller than all
and rank of Z smaller than M minus or
okay and you can show and this is the in
the paper of near a nested and
schönefeld is essentially these will be
irreducible okay on each one of these
this is this is what I call V R okay
these are this form an irreducible
decomposition of the of this of this
algebraic variety and no sorry I mean
these are all irreducible and they cover
somehow this okay but but what is what
is what is potentially the case is that
it may be that one
VR is not necessarily actually in in
this in this algebraic variety because
it doesn't touch I mean it doesn't touch
the real semi same algebraic said the
boundary okay but but really the main
point that I want to make here and and
this is the main is the word irreducible
here is really key okay because if I
show that for a certain value of our
okay that this VR touches this thing
okay then I know that the whole VR has
to be inside okay and really the degrees
of the VR are the ones that were
computed in this paper by Nia understand
and spoonfuls okay so okay you need we
need a little bit of machinery to show
that there is a certain R for which it
will be contained in here but then if we
do this and then we essentially do an
analysis and asymptotic analysis of this
algebraic degrees so we show that the
Russia two to the M square for a certain
value of our okay we can get we somehow
get the result okay sorry I'm a bit out
of time so I have to be a bit quick but
this is roughly the the idea of of the
proof so okay so just to wrap up so so
so I think when one important question
is to know if the lower bound can be
improved if we assume the convex body C
to be a pollito yes with this we don't
know I mean because we don't have any
example for which for which this is
tight what but where the C is really a
polytope in particular what is the
positive semi definite rank of regular
polygons in the plane with them and then
there are a couple of other questions
that maybe I'm just keeping I'm finished
here thanks a lot
[Applause]
yes do we have what sorry we don't have
any so we just have a construction of
log of size log N and the lower bound is
root log N and we don't know if it's
where is it so for the LP with a lot of
people on this type of it for polygons
it's time for polygons size for the
parameter hydron also alright so this is
the construction of Governments where he
used sorting networks to get an N log n
so that's we don't know and that's why
actually it would be interesting to to
understand this question I mean if we
can prove that it's log D for for
polytopes then we will show that it's
not possible but we don't know
what's a candidate for this explicitly I
don't know no no I have no it seems I
think what we would need I mean so so
from the construction here I mean I have
some indication of what the subs I mean
what did I mention it should be I mean
the dementia should really be in the
half of the dimension I mean should be
in the bad kind of regime I think it
should not be very symmetric it seems to
be this these things I mean as soon as
you're symmetric it seems that the two
to the M Squared drops to two to the M
somehow not sure exactly why but this
seems to be kind of what and but yeah I
don't have any any explicit
[Music]
[Applause]